Riyadh is an international city a third
of the population comes from abroad many
of them manual workers they helped to
build the Saudi capital but the Welcome
they once enjoyed is starting to fake
Saudis first now that's the Saudi
government's plan to reduce unemployment
among native Saudis employers who hire
non Saudis will have to pay higher fees
and jobs in shops like this one selling
electronics for example will be
restricted to Saudis only foreigners
will be banned from at least 12 jobs
this music stores selling instruments
has already put up a sign for Saudis
only we are looking for a salesperson
MELAS Asian is a good idea there are
more job opportunities here for Saudis
than for foreigners a lot of sad is
returned from the US and Germany with
degrees only to find many jobs already
filled by foreigners their own country
should benefit from them as Saudi Arabia
should benefit from Saudis we are in a
neighborhood in the south of the city
it's a tough area most of the people
here are foreign workers mantra here is
from Bangladesh he arrived a month ago
to work in this shop learning how to
assemble picture frames is getting more
expensive and the seller isn't enough
for everyone
it's hurt it's hard to survive for the
person's life for manual workers was
never easy in Saudi Arabia just as in
many parts of the world
but falling oil prices have made it more
difficult energy prices doubled in a
year pushing up prices and recently new
taxes on basic goods added an extra
burden it's evening Mucha here has just
finished his shift how many hours did
you work today actually I worked 16
hours that's a lot maybe it for that but
I need to do that
for the salary he makes 1300 Saudi riyal
a month that's about 350 US dollars on
the way home he tells me he used to have
a good life until his father got very
sick you know we lost almost all of our
money and his treatments so I just
thought that I should come here to keep
them alive being the eldest and the
family he bore the responsibility he
dropped out of engineering studies and
came to Saudi Arabia to earn money it
wasn't as easy as yet expected life is
becoming more difficult for most of the
people of other countries all losing
their job and even he'll give the cause
they're leaving Saudi Arabia because you
know they ran out of job and they can't
live like that
maybe my boss gave me a place to live
but all the bosses are not like that
even some of people don't have a job
sometimes they sleeps near the road they
don't have time money to buy food mantra
here chooses not to show me the room he
lives in with three others he doesn't
want to get into trouble and be sent
home he wants to stay as long as he can
to make money for his
he's just one of millions of foreign
workers in Saudi Arabia they are
realizing though that the future here
belongs to Saudis